gang let's talk about that live stream
baby we're doing it live January 1st
Live from Tony seven o'clock Eastern
Standard time it's going to be a good
good time come hang out with us we're
gonna have some friends over we're gonna
have a little appearance from Denise and
Patty a couple of Pops come hang with
the boys yeah it's gonna be a good time
baby link is in the description
moment.co
ayg and that ain't it we got our third
show on sale right now at The Gramercy
theater let's go the army of garbage
came correct in New York City sold out
two shows we added our third links in
the description let's party baby Friday
February 3rd we'll see you there see you
there welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
were you ever big into auto trader
magazine nope ever ruined a family
vacation or gathering I mean probably
this week if I had to get a couple times
a couple a cup of a fair amount of times
like straight like everyone left too
drunk or you said something uh a number
of times yeah
hey you showed us a toothbrush all right
yeah
um do you cut your burger in half when
you eat it 100 gentle really 100 we can
take the steak knife from a nice
steakhouse no
when was the last time you stole a pint
glass from a bar
probably pretty recently Yeah well yeah
just because I I make Irish exits Irish
goodbyes so well you sneak the beer out
so you can have I don't know why could I
just walk it yeah you kind of got that
cachet now yeah yeah
I got struck by lightning I don't know
what's going on
in the last 365 days have you [ __ ] in
your pants oh God yeah are you [ __ ]
serious Mr private Lounge over here hey
boys
you need
um all right anyone in your family play
semi-pro football no okay
you ever wore pants that zip into shorts
yeah that's a very Florida yeah you
gotta be ready to party they only zip
once and then you never go back you're
like well it looks like I have shorts
now I lost that leg Yeah that's what
nobody thinks about you gotta walk
around with a half a set of pants in
your pockets where you gonna put your
toothbrush
um magazines in the bathroom yes okay
have you ever had a quail egg yes yes
yes yes yes you like it I love them I
just had [ __ ] about 15 the other day
15. yeah I had a full [ __ ] jar big
omelette yeah I've got a large amount of
quail eggs I love I actually love quail
eggs a 15 Queen what is this I'm gonna
come in a jar we got a jar of quail eggs
I hate all of them I ate them in the
[ __ ] car ride over I couldn't stop
eating them I love quail eggs wait they
were hard-boiled yeah oh hard boiled
I've had I've had I've had every type of
quail now that you say that I really
enjoyed duck eggs I love eggs I love
eggs I like eggs too I like eggs what do
you do if you crack an egg and there's
like the double yolk oh Jack call yeah
it's good right I jack off that's good I
take time I take pictures of it I take
pictures of it I post it on Instagram I
send it to Rogan look what my [ __ ]
look what my chickens are doing yeah
yeah it's a good time Root Beer Birch
Beer root beer hmm you didn't you could
have said anything after that you have a
specific brand that you like no I and W
barks what we have on the bus I love a w
uh-huh uh but I love going and finding
small like of course if you're from you
got Philly Roots check out Hanks
I'll tell you right now in a parallel
universe I am Brewing root beer in
Northern Washington
with a beautiful blonde Swedish wife six
kids and a shitload of quail eggs and
[ __ ] and a lot of Saint Bernards
uh you got the tour bus now is there is
there an essential item for the tour bus
that really UPS the quality of life for
you
uh yeah a water pick
I couldn't get into it I tried it I
couldn't get into it I like it I water
picked probably twice a day I love water
I tried I bought why everybody was
raving I got one I just didn't stick
it's lost every day I floss every day
you do yeah you do old school flosser
the pics
I'll you and let me tell you something
they're fantastic if I find a pic I know
it's mine I'll use it again wow do you
smell them always oh you gotta smell
them hit me fingers fingers on this On
The Floss run them down and then to the
night I told him that he was mine was
blown you gotta stop the tune it ever
since some of the rapist [ __ ] you've
ever had in your life dude I have a hole
in one of my molars that's why I'm water
picking so much lately and I in the
morning I will I will water pick that
hole and the smell that comes out is so
aggressive yeah
it's like bacteria I'll show it to you
take a look
beware oh right there yeah and uh it's a
good looking tongue though thank you
looks like he was chewing firecrackers
oh I have oh I should tell you this I
got hit in the mouth of the baseball bat
when I was 11 and I lost 26 teeth
all the teeth you see who has that many
teeth you have 32.
32.
I'm an [ __ ]
it's like I've been 10 split Jesus
Christ but you never cried on your teeth
no I've never counted my teeth
a great question how many teeth do you
think you think you have
115 I don't know two 220. whatever it
takes you know what I mean what movies
is that from
Mr Mom Mr Mom Michael Keaton what are
you working on some electrical work yeah
what are you doing do you want to do 20
whatever it takes yeah why don't you
come on in here Ron so you're doing a
little more time off people can I grab
one more shut up
that's [ __ ] great yeah yeah freaking
beers with the machine during the day
let's [ __ ]
this is it this is what we play for uh
have you ever had one of those magic
wallets
of course I did
if you're getting a baked potato what
are the toppings that you'd prefer on it
you're not gonna like this he's gonna
paint his Masterpiece just butter I'm
all right with that classic right in the
middle put one full stick of butter on a
baked potato
I [ __ ] love butter it's a big one for
mistake you're talking to a huge butter
man I use it like icing I'm telling you
it's not good I use it can I tell you I
dated a chick who put it on a Pop-Tart
one time the game changer someone was
just talking about that I'll give you
something get a honey bun
put in the microwave with the butter on
top for like look at them his eyes just
rolled back and it's burnt for like 12
seconds
enter Nirvana unbelievable my daughter
puts them on Oreos butter on Oreos but
she put man she has a butter problem
she just gave up veganism so Isla my
youngest was like one day came out and
said I'm going vegan and we're like
that's stupid it's like I'm going vegan
I have headaches and I think it'll get
rid of them and so she was vegan for
like
six months seven months maybe since
April April right
the other night she comes down she goes
I'm done let's get a pizza I said why
don't she goes Pizza sausage and onion
and then we're like okay and then then
the next day she goes steak I need a
steak back on the horse and then we went
to in and out last night for dinner I
mean she is [ __ ] back and she's nice
down that burger
yeah [ __ ] punching cows when she
walks by them [ __ ] don't look at me uh
Pop-Tarts are toaster strudel Pop Tarts
oh wait toast them Strudels
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh toast them strudels that's the
Mandalorian effect you're talking about
which they were awesome when we were
kids but I don't know about now now the
Pop-Tart has really really come into
itself yeah they really know what
they're doing I'll tell you what hot or
cold I I'll tell you what when
especially when someone takes something
that's industrial corporate and then
makes it thrown have you had homemade
Pop-Tarts no how do you do that I get
them like a lot of people will bake
stuff for our show like they'll bake a
stuff we had a woman not trying to throw
anyone under the bus we had a woman one
time because I like I like Uncrustables
yeah she made me an uncrustable donut
her homemade uncrustable donut wow that
was so good wow Tim Dillon woke up at
six in the morning and got an Uber to
her place and bought some for himself
before we left that morning they were
that [ __ ] shout out to Timmy yeah
Kimmy D knows what he feels like that
but I've had homemade Pop-Tarts and they
are wow I never even thought of that if
there was just a little more filling in
them yeah they got to be like the double
stuff so homemade Pop-Tarts probably are
probably like this big this this but
they're this thing they [ __ ] come in
your mouth talking about will you do a
fig newton a hundred percent a sleeve of
figment yes you can't just I don't do
one cookie I'm not a one cookie guy I'm
a I'm a I really want anything I'm gonna
I'm I'm gonna suck down a regrettable
amount of cookies
favorite cookie one cookie what is it
Oreos I have a problem standard straight
up regular Double Stuffed double stop
okay you ever put them in milk and
crunch them up you need to make cereal
I'm sorry I apologize yeah I didn't mean
to insult a gentleman yeah
dude I'll take I'll take Nutter Butters
and leave them on the counter for an
evening so they get stale and they're
soft and with when it comes to Oreos I
soak them I take the fork shove it in
the icing and then I stick it in the
[ __ ] thing until it's [ __ ] good
and then pulled out still attached to
the fork and to the mouth God because
the icing's hard and the cookies soft
yeah I love it yeah it's something else
this is a big one okay this might
determine
a lot okay I'm gonna give you two
choices
Hellman's mayonnaise or Miracle Whip oh
helmets
had yet scored it from the premises I
made the big mistake in College of
getting Miracle Whip thinking it was
mayonnaise it ain't and it stinks and I
I because I I like mayonnaise sardines
and saltine crackers whoa mayonnaise
sardines sardines and saltine crackers
how are things in the 20s Jesus Christ
isn't that what they ate in The Burbs in
that movie The Weird Family
that's Civil War [ __ ] right there Jesus
that's right Finland [ __ ] who does that
I loved it especially served on the
Titanic it's so [ __ ] good this guy's
old assaulting a dab of mayonnaise with
the with the Sardine and uh and I and I
picked up uh Miracle Whip and I was
trying to explain to a girl how good it
was and I used Miracle Whip instead and
all of a sudden I put it in my mouth I
was like this is
get it out I got the wrong thing in my
mouth this is peanut butter Miracle Whip
stinks I have to ask just because it's
standard operating procedure what's the
credit score like uh
um I mean probably fine like yeah a
thousand there's no way you have
blemishes at this point it's Stellar I
don't know what it is it's got to be
exemplary yeah what kind of what kind of
stuff again no disrespect no I don't
know I don't know the score but it's
definitely fine admirable yeah yeah of
course yeah
um what kind of Steel you're walking
around with Amex
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
I have one for touring one for one for
business obviously yeah actually I have
three because I have one for personal
purchases one for related to podcast
stuff of course it's a touring yeah all
right yeah I got a debit card I have
millions of points yeah real millions
millions no we have I just looked this
morning what 149 000. holy [ __ ] it's
about four dollars we get a race car
maybe it could you maybe could actually
yeah that's Jack [ __ ] when it comes to
Amex points I'm waiting for them to call
me be like you have to use these yeah
yeah really that's all trashy we are I
look to see the equivalent I could get
in American Express gift cards
Christmas bonus is coming up
everybody wins do you have a Capital One
card
do you want one I get 500 bucks if I do
I get 500 if I sign up a friend
no no no no no
we just we just started making money
about dude it's [ __ ] congratulations
yeah it's [ __ ] awesome it's a foot
off the neck for sure it is and it
should be celebrated I have a real
problem with people well that's what
I've always respected about you you
don't a lot of people hide that they fly
private you're like I'm flying like I'm
doing it we're blowing it as we make it
dude we just lost ten thousand dollars
on a
it should be celebrated you know you got
to be smart with it but you should have
fun with it and um by the way I could
not do this the tour that I'm on could
not do it uh flying oh no it would be
impossible sure you had your tour is the
stupidest of all time proper nuts it's
proper insane I mean I'm at over 200
shows
right now on the tour and there's one
year left on the tour can't do that wait
in a Delta Lounge we would [ __ ] it I
think the whole tour crew would be dead
it was like [ __ ] six of it they're
all they're like right now they go like
we're all wiped and I'm like yeah they
go you really need to take a break I'm
like yeah no I'm going to do press okay
there you go it's a worker we're boys
with pop we're good friends with Potter
and we were talking oh he's great I love
yeah he's great um and we were talking
to him one time he had just got back
opening up speaking of gentlemen oh my
God the classiest he's the reason we
asked the street name because he grew up
on like you know Route 87 like a proper
turn he could see you could see a toll
booth out front of his house he is one
of my absolute favorites oh dude yeah
we're just with him we were asking him
and he were like we're like oh he's like
yeah I was out with Tom he's like I'm
just such an idiot he's like I don't
understand levels of success to the
point where he was like oh what time's
your flight you're like I'm leaving
after the [ __ ] show and he's like it
didn't even comprehend he's like I
thought he was just gonna go to the
airport
he's the best he's great did you collect
anything growing up Chinese stars
nunchucks I like to have Beanie Babies
commemorative places
there was anybody in the 80s I mean
first of all I was taking Taekwondo
and I had like a strip mall like a tiger
Schulman's yeah yeah and here's the
thing I was pretty highly ranked like
we're like in retrospect I'm like they
were just like could you pay for another
round and they're like here's another a
tiger Schulman really pulled I must have
been looking at you like I remember I
remember walking out of a class I got
him from his ballot I was like eight or
nine and a like a 40 year old man was
like Jesus Christ this kid could kill
somebody
he's gonna register his hands like and I
was just like I mean I was this [ __ ]
sweet gentle kid you got a Slurpee in
your hand and then we started to get it
because we're taking those classes yeah
we're getting into like nunchucks
Chinese stars pretending we're ninjas
give myself black eyes yeah
oh [ __ ] beautiful when you when you
first started making money was there any
like silly purchase yeah you're a dirt
bike I didn't need those something
stupid jet ski yeah well I have two uh
you have two now yeah are they at the
house yeah we live on the lake so yeah
oh really like you can walk out your
backyard and go to a lake I have a boat
and yeah in the backyard damn yeah
cigarette boat no be cool you running
blow what do you mean who the [ __ ] has a
cigarette boat in the lake yeah
[ __ ] That's how little you know about
boats damn dude really he's walk down
the light you got a pool back there too
hot tub
yeah he said 200 cities you idiot what
the [ __ ] who's doing 200 cities of a
goddamn hot dog what kind of lawnmower
do you have now
that's a John Deere uh it's a push mower
though I want to stay home it's a
plug-in takes me about three days to
know that's the trashiest
um and you have to plug in your
lawnmower oh the dumbest thing right
away was a pen a pen like you know I was
like in a store here's the thing you
ever feel guilty in store like I was I
felt guilty to buy something yeah and I
was like I need to use the bathroom you
know and there was like a nice store and
then I was like I'll buy something like
and I bought a pen it was like 100 it
was like 500 what yeah and then I left
and I'm sorry
different colors it's so stupid it was
one of those real like a nice like this
is definitely not be mentioning that I
bought this that was one of those things
you're like keep this to your [ __ ]
self
that was so dumb
hey we got an eight ball I got a new pen
I got a pen like was it a cross pen
those are hot for a while those were hot
yeah there was could never write with
them they'd slip out of your hand Mont
Blanc and then yeah then Cartier yeah
those are nice ones are you double
jointed
uh no I used to be able to take my index
fingers and touch my wrist here for a
long time and then it finally like I
could go and circus you know like you're
like an X-Men like pretty far but like
it used to be able to touch here and
that stopped at some point can you Gleek
no I wish I it happens only on yeah yeah
I always tie we know a kid that could do
it and a continuous stream that's
amazing oh dude I don't understand how
it happened now but of course
we were in a car and we saw him on his
on his school bus we stopped a school
bus and made him get off and do it it's
a clique for you dude it was [ __ ]
stop the bus we got a gleeker back there
uh have you ever skied in jeans
probably yeah yeah because in uh
that's one of those things like you know
those um
socio-economic bumps of course that
we've now are skiing well we're in like
Minneapolis so like you can go but we're
not buying you all new gears sure yeah
so yeah for sure it was a pair of jeans
you're a kid in that in a city like that
you're just out in jeans every day in
snow and like it's the worst right it's
just there's so much snow it's cold as
[ __ ] yeah and you're just yeah you're in
wet denim all the time it [ __ ] sucks
yikes have you ever had one of those
trick voicemails where you go hello what
was that Hello haha
no I believe it or not
um
[Laughter]
oh when you guys are going to dinner as
a family as a kid what would you ever
order the same thing
like everyone gets the lemon chicken or
the chicken it wasn't like that okay it
was the [ __ ] worst my dad used to go
um like he had like this like anxiety of
like let's get home like always so my
dad had it it's like a [ __ ] base camp
I mean always everybody get get the
whole [ __ ] so you're right social
anxiety yes they didn't understand that
he didn't understand so like we're all
having dinner right and it's like it'd
be like if you guys it was that guy was
looking at me you're still eating like
you're eating and he would take his bite
and he would go ready to go like we're
all eating right now man and he's like
oh okay and then he would just be like
[Laughter]
you ready now and you're like can we
just [ __ ] it and let me choke her like
relax
always gotta go yeah um never will you
take leftover leftovers home now like if
you go out to a restaurant if you're not
on tours it's you and it's you and your
wife the family go out very rarely dude
I don't really I don't like to I mean
it's more like I don't know I just feel
like whatever you ate is what you ate
that's what I'm saying yeah yeah it's
like I'm not taking this these last four
bites of lemon chicken yeah you know
right right yeah all right if we're
doing the restaurant let's get in let's
get into it okay
um I go I go large I know yeah well you
order first of all when is the situation
where you're not paying where where it's
not your show
it's rare I would assume agents probably
taking you out they'll pick it up you're
a show in the city what if it's you and
Rogan out to dinner are you fighting
over the check I try splitting it no
okay no I try I pick you out of this
room I've tried
I've tried to and I've have um given the
card if I know I'm having dinner with
Joe or ahead of time yeah put it on that
yeah make sure you put it on here yes I
did that this weekend down the shore
that's a nice move yeah
kind of go to my mom yeah I like I like
you know if you can afford to do it it's
nice to be able to treat people too yeah
also so you don't have that weird let me
get it like you just go it's taken care
of he's always paid for a [ __ ]
everything for years of course of course
yeah it does okay yeah he does all right
that's good
um order appetizers for the table for
everybody you like to do that I do that
a lot nice I just I think we get to you
know we're on the road yeah you and the
crew goes out we sit down I'll be like
hey can you bring out like three of them
yeah you do that like hey get these
we're still we're we're still figuring
it out let's start dropping stuck in
asparagus put some [ __ ] food out here
man have you ever ordered everything off
the menu yes really give me everything I
went uh there was this uh this french
guy
um [ __ ] what is his name he owns a Trey
uh
[ __ ] he's uh I might follow him on
Instagram and he would do these pop-ups
that were just [ __ ] unbelievable okay
in Austin no in L.A
um and I'm trying to remember his name
Trey Griffith no no I was saying Trey
like French oh okay his name is uh Ludo
uh Ludo Le Febreze I wasn't that bad so
he owns um
and he is duolingual that's pretty good
too I think he has a he might have a
Michelin star anyway he would do these
pop-ups in La for a while meaning like
you know just take over a space and so
the first time I went I had a few things
and I was like holy [ __ ] this is so like
so incredible like you know like yeah of
course so the next time he had a pop-up
and I got a table I looked at the menu I
was like yes and they're like yes I go
yes everything yeah bring everything run
me through the [ __ ] make me sick yeah
yeah that was the [ __ ] we're just
starting to eat at places where we're
like oh that's I we took there's this
place where we had it was like the best
burger in the city we all took a bite
and I was like I didn't know rich people
have been eating different as well
there's a difference they really it's
there's really here's the let me tell
you the best thing about money the best
thing about money I'm listening it is
not toys it is not stuff it is options
options to do things yes that other
people don't want to have to do this
yeah and to make life easier easier in
other words a simple version of it would
be like bacon on your burger bacon on
your burger or like to park here's 20
bucks when you're struggling you're like
I'm not gonna waste 20 dollars I'll
drive over there yeah 20 bucks part the
the more and more things come like that
that have a an option for you yeah right
um and you can remove any I use it to
like remove anxiety remove thought
remove like yeah I can just put the car
here and not have to worry about that
I'm gonna get it we're kind of doing
that now but we really can't afford it
well look this patreon's [ __ ] blowing
up you heard it here www
uh billion hours of content but food is
like one of the greatest luggages being
able to eat at a great place what would
be the most if if it sticks out that you
ever spent on a meal uh
uh I don't know if you want me to tell
you oh yeah we do I want you want to
write it down like a rich guy yes I'm
gonna read it out loud
it wasn't long ago yeah
oh yeah there you go it's this was uh
this is a first finally I got something
pretty elaborate okay dinner I had okay
throw the credit card number down there
too just uh maybe a Pinsky if you got it
also how much cash do you have on you
right now
I don't know okay let me count
what the [ __ ] let me say it
yeah give me how many people were there
it's just you
it was uh ladies and gentlemen
it was a group it was a group okay but I
mean what city
Chicago can I say what the number is
do you think we should we talked
honestly this is what people tune in for
all right sure
52 000.
it was my birthday
that's your birthday of course blow it
the [ __ ] out is that with tip that was
with tip all right with tip yeah hey
what's five percent of 52 000. I figure
with wine and tax it's really only 38.
holy [ __ ] Camp how about that butcher
box baby I mean come on it's cold
outside you know I love that butcher box
what are we doing here gang maybe you're
a Grill Master maybe you fancy yourself
as a good guy on the grill but where are
you getting your meat from that's the
big question that's what matters aguino
makes a good steak a good steak you know
has good steak butcher box free range
grass-fed grass finish sure uh wild
caught wild caught the whole nine yards
man if you're looking for good meat you
want to get yourself butcher box get
that on the grill yeah butcher box has a
special offer for our listeners butcher
boxes offering new members two free New
York strips plus eight ounces of gold
crack Lobster in your first box plus ten
dollars off butcher box what are you
doing you're gonna go out of business
surfing Turf right there put your boxes
Lobster is well caught uh by independent
Harvesters of course in the North
Atlantic and then pressure extracted
from the claws and Knuckles so you get
the most delicious sucking Lobster you
ever done I'm talking about uh we've
said it time and time again we're big
fans of the butcher box over there at
the Ryan house I still got a whole
freezer of it I had some ground beef the
other day mix it up couple of sweet
potatoes some of the spices the bird
does it I'll take some of them strips
butcher boxes offering our listeners
free New York strip and lobster plus ten
dollars off in your first box sign up
today at butcherbox.com
ayg to get two
10 ounce New York strips takes eight
ounces of Lobster Claw knuckle meat
knuckle me baby let's go free knuckle
meat what are we doing plus ten dollars
off your first boss at butcherbox.com
ayg for the knuckle me go yeah gang got
a little reminder from our good friends
at manscape uh-huh keep those balls
clean and tight yeah we're on a tight
ship down there New Year's Eve's coming
up you don't want to get [ __ ] caught
in the bushes if you know what I mean
get get your zipper
yikes do yourself a favor gang get over
to the man's gate grab one of them
lawnmower 4.0 one of their premium
packages everything that they got is
absolutely fantastic I clean you up
smell good smell great feel good [ __ ]
like a champ I'll give your lady
something to kiss at midnight what the
hey manscape clean it up is a family
program
guys you get 20 off plus free shipping
with the code garbage at manscape.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
code garbage at manscape.com I've been
telling you for years now they were one
of the first sponsors of the Pod yes
they were
from forever ago I got about two
treaties at the house I use it on my
ball sack my butthole my face I should
have used it a couple days ago cleaned
up trimmed I went to the car wash as
they say all right throw it in the
shower that's all that's the only place
I do it one more time baby that's 20 off
plus free shipping with the code garbage
at manstate got manscape.com
and we would love uh the original
grilled stuff burrito at Taco Bell the
original which had the creamy pepper
Jacks remember the original I've tweeted
at them the original menu at Taco Bell
was [ __ ] top shelf ring back to cool
Sabrina and then the original Monterey
ranch chicken sandwich at Wendy's
it's lighting up when he's talking about
this bacon in the ranch
chopped up bacon in the ranch it was in
a gold wrapper [ __ ] you you know exactly
what I'm talking about it was uh that's
when they tried the classic chicken
patty Monterey whatever thing cheese
monterey jack monterey jack if it wasn't
um and Monterey Jack cheese lettuce
tomato bacon and then ranch with bacon
in it it was yeah it was something else
those were the things I remember growing
up obviously I love McDonald's Filet
fishes I love the Roy Rogers fixing bar
I love the pizza I had enough love a
Pizza Hut lunch buffet
Pizza Hut lunch box saying all the right
things they were like 395 or something
four dollars that you can eat for the
week and then they had a dessert pizza a
little caramel apple dessert I mean
Christ what was the going out to dinner
situation for the Dillons as a kid what
would be well so my uncle is a big
restaurant guy so every now and then
we'd get to go into whatever yeah
is that's what's so interesting about
you you're from that but you have I have
severely yeah
I have some high-end taste because my
uncle's a big restaurant guy so we used
to get to go
we used to get to go to restaurants and
eat really nice food every now and then
would it be known that it's we're going
out with uncle oh yeah and where the
parents go or he would take you parents
we'd all go to the family sure but
everybody knew he was paying oh yeah
everyone knew that they didn't have to
pass I thought they were gone but then
so big night out for us would be like
you know maybe my parents hated each
other so it was rare that they both go
out
when they both go out and beat us some
local Diner or a place called itkins in
Valley Stream which was like an old you
know like an old like Malt Shop an old
ice cream party great ice cream sock it
to me Sunday 15 Scoops a lot of people
yeah yeah oh you're sharing them
everything but but the kitchen sink
Sunday yeah
um a little bacon ranch on there yeah it
was wild they would go to usually it
would be a diner or a maybe a little
greek place or a diner or a place called
mcquaid's like a birthday dinner a
graduation dinner what are we thinking
maybe an Italian spot okay chains
Applebee's Oliver Fridays so we grew up
with Fridays and out back a little
towards the Outback came in later
Fridays was a go-to the tostado nachos
where you split a taco shell down the
middle hit it with refried to cheese
um Fridays when they brought out to Jack
Daniels pulled pork sandwich it changed
my life
oh yeah I get it the Jack Daniel's menu
where's your 911. yeah you're not
kidding every week did Jack Daniel's
menu at Fridays made me know what was
possible
outside of Long Island in a way that I
like is this so [ __ ] good what you
want to hear an order this is my order
of Fridays you want to get
I'd go in there
as a kid as a child
this is what I used to do listen honey
get your pen and paper
tostado nachos
salad with because I love the Friday
salad because they loaded it with cheese
croutons bacon that's shredded cheddar
cheese you get the breadsticks salad
with ranch tostado nachos salad with
ranch pulled pork sandwich it comes with
french fries and on to that the loaded
baked potato now the loaded baked
potatoes what little kids get a loaded
baked potato how's the divorce going on
a smart holy [ __ ] a smart one because
here's what I would do I would get the
extra Jack Daniel sauce and it would go
right into the potato and then like you
have this loaded baked potato sauce
still every now and then if I'm on the
road I'll go into Fridays get a loaded
Mash throw some Jack Daniels sauce on
there and eat it what are your parents
saying when you're when you're making
this order
they're kind of just fine with it
they're just like impressed that I can
order I'm like you know a lot of kids
are like yeah yeah yeah tell them what
you want that kind of thing you're
speaking a lot of kids are like
you know so at least you're like you can
talk yeah you know I'm not on the
tostado nachos are they good today
um who's cooking well you know the
answer to that is they were horrible
parents
well I feel like the 90s like that was
wide open no the 90s nobody cared the
Boomer and I'm working on a book right
now about Boomers and the way they
parent it and it's really like
amazing to watch the difference between
the way we were parented it's crazy oh
it's nuts my parents might have said a
few times hey you should go to college
but they took no interest like the idea
of like them like going around the
schools for like the weekend oh won't
you have fun here you'll like it here
like they were such deeply selfish
people that had no designs on me
becoming a productive human being at all
they were incredibly selfish you know
um
you know morally questionable demons
from hell we basically were just sharing
sounds like a nice little Saturday I
mean you know you guys were like
roommates we were we were just kind of
like hanging out yeah we're just hanging
out
I get it oh yeah for sure I remember
even like thinking I don't think I went
on visit I went to I visited one college
I think by myself yeah I used to smoke
cigarettes in my grandmother's house
when I was like 13 14 just in the house
did she know they knew she knew yeah I
would smoke cigarettes in the house they
didn't care they didn't care yeah that's
[ __ ] my friend's mother used to let
us do Coke weed everything everybody my
parents didn't do that they hated drugs
everybody's got that one friend's house
I was I remember sitting in something
like I shouldn't [ __ ] be here right
this is bad right this is not great
you're always thinking like when are
your parents coming home yeah they're
just never and then they're home doing
drugs with us and we're like oh you guys
my wife's mother was a prostitute really
she made a lot of money in the 70s in
the city high-end call girl and bought a
house and everything great good looking
like she was then uh-huh she knew how to
she knew how to package and she said
clean the pipes
her words not mine over a white pie yeah
all right let's get into some cues here
because we want to find out where you
stand on a lot of stuff yeah yeah you're
gonna set yeah you know we claim to be
experts at it but you
you can really set the tone or set those
I can you can lay the wall yeah with
certain things before that though what
was your first stupid purchase when you
got when you when you got money what was
the Range Rover and I sold it months
later really because with the supply
chain you can sell it pretty easily I
just realized I'm like it was way too
much money for a car
um and how long ago was this is somewhat
real a year ago really yeah and I just
realized I'm like I don't care that much
immediately you go I don't care like I
drive it for a while it's nice great
[ __ ] car but then I go ah I don't
need it I'd rather have the money for
other [ __ ] what is it now what are you
whipping around in right now I just have
rentals but I think I'm gonna get an
electric okay electric Caribbean one of
those new ones I I got on a list for
that a list yes
no more Jack Daniels sauce for this game
I'll tell you that right no in Arabian
yeah it just goes quietly but it's a
it's not that expensive it'll be is that
that you know you'll you you uh you'll
pay the lease through your business of
course smoke in the car
I mean when you lease you can
I like how that's what you're worried
about like that's gonna come somebody at
the Ford dealership coming after you
well I don't know I mean we're I'm
trying to stop I stopped for months and
then I go back and then I start eating
the car you have to
I mean those baked potatoes don't hold
all right best answer ever
my favorite thing is going to the drive
through with the radios on listening to
something and I'm just [ __ ] drive
through food if you eat it in your home
you feel insane that's I never got that
I pull up and park right away absolutely
right away yeah you bring it to your
house and unflake
kitchen table your psychology have you
ever seen McDonald's on a plate that
means people are way too comfortable oh
you've settled in for this life of hell
yeah that's a real weird I've seen it
I've seen McDonald's on a plate the only
one you could get away with a little bit
is KFC sure that's it yeah they sold
that hard yeah that's right bring it
home to the fan because it did bigger
portions too I mean I man KFC honey
barbecue wings which if this continued
uh I mean KFC was a beautiful part when
they started [ __ ] with dessert when
they were giving out whole cakes called
a little bucket parfait they're
unbelievable with strawberry and there
was chocolate and they were unbelievable
and the chocolate had
you what the [ __ ] going on here I've
never even heard it happened Sherry here
they got him in the back it was
unbelievable it had a layer of um uh
like a graham cracker on the bottom
pudding and then a whipped cream and
then a foil on top oh the foil on top
the chocolate sprinkle had just kind of
like the dive the sprinkle it kind of
started out a little bit bled out a
little bit and it bled out onto the
whipped cream that's the flavor I have
offered thousands of dollars to get one
of them and I cannot like I would buy
them like I've offered thousands of
dollars for it
somewhere I hope something
where do you stand on splitting the
check where you had them hate it hate it
hate it okay hate it so what do you do
what's the move
you get them the next time okay you get
them the next time now for many years I
was the guy that got you the next time
there was no next time
there was not a gonna be enough until
about three weeks ago I was that guy my
dad tells a great story about a guy who
used to always get everyone at the
office to go out for lunch let's go here
for lunch you want to go here for lunch
and then you get you know everybody
would eat and then the guy would go like
this you go I'm a little light and then
everyone would pay for the guy and the
guy just kept getting away with it I'm a
little like it's such a dirtbag oh man
I'm a little alive try to save a little
bit of I'm a little bit like I got about
eight bucks what a great life
fantastic that's the yikes do you think
appetizers should be ordered
individually or should they be ordered
for the table for the table and shared
they should never be ordered
individually do you think it's trashy if
multiple people at the same table order
the same dish I would go this far okay I
almost think at a steakhouse there
should be a little meeting up front and
then one person should order for the
whole table
we just did that yeah just have a
meeting just like that just have a
meeting have a little meeting what do
you like you're medium rare you this
you're that you're rare your medium will
compromise and medium rare what do we do
it's just a family style thing let's one
guy come here here are the apps we want
here are the entrees we want it is not
an individual thing I think you order
steak for the table sides for the table
yes that to me is the steakhouse
anything that's what I believe that's
what I believe that's all right yeah you
know so what I was taught if you go out
to dinner if you're bringing your
friends out to dinner it's Tim's dinner
yeah are you are you you're leading that
charge you're handling I'm usually
leading the charge because my friend get
letting my friends order would be like
giving them ape the Constitution I'm
telling them the fashion of effect of
government like my friends are idiots
and they'll mispronounce words and they
don't know anything
yeah I like it when you do when you do a
steakhouse you got to start with a
shellfish town hour if you can if people
Seafood Tower cold Seafood Tower first
thing to hit the table is a cold Seafood
Tower first thing boom boom oyster
shrimp lobster crab little clams
whatever that's out cold appetizers are
done
then you bring in the hot appetizers if
you're gonna do any of them maybe it's a
warm goat cheese salad maybe it's a
lobster bisque it's not my business
maybe it's a baked clams maybe it's a
shrimp scampi whatever it is maybe it's
a Gorgonzola bread a garlic bread with
Gorgonzola cheese sauce yeah a little
bit but there's got to be a little hot
appetizer Yes actually just a little a
little nibble then there's a salad for
the table then you hit the porterhouse
for two three four whatever
deal Groton the line it whatever you
want to do cream spinach cream spinach
broccoli garlic and oil asparagus
whatever how does that stay cooked I
like rare but on certain Cuts I'll go
medium rare wow you're a rare I'm a rare
guy yeah sometimes I'll do a medium well
teach that nope sometimes I'll do a
medium rare if it's a rib eye the
fattier a steak the longer it should be
cooked so if you do a rib eye steak
really should be medium rare
filet or anything like that is rare to
Black and Blue Sushi great
um damn but wow a bone in New York strip
usually rare plus that's the term you go
rear plus yeah meaning rare but a little
more than racism a bone-in strap
anything with a bone you're gonna do
rare plus rib eyes medium rare
anything strip steaks fillets rare
to black and blue Pittsburgh style which
is Sushi [ __ ] laying it down bro
everyone's [ __ ] taking notes out
there take notes Jesus I was just in the
Philippines three weeks ago nice right
and you can't drink that water yeah you
get diarrhea but um how is the food good
why pollute
you did you know what it is now you know
what balut is look it up I don't even
know how to spell it b-a-l-u-t I don't
think it's Pizza it's not street food
fertilized developing egg embryos
I can see them Bobby those other photos
there's a picture of Bobby with two
thumbs up look at that that's a bird all
right so what they do is they'll boil a
duck egg right maybe two days before it
hatches that's a hatchable egg right and
so it's it's you eat that so I had one
how was that well well when you when you
so when you crunch down on the skull the
brain squirts in your mouth
and then you get the feather stuck
between your teeth but other than that
[Laughter]
but so like yeah that's what you want
your first time having it yeah I I yeah
because I known about you know so it
wasn't good
well honestly if I closed my eyes and I
just ate it I just like oh is this egg
but like you know I mean with more
dryness you know I mean to it you know
but when you when you have eyeballs
right like this yeah and you look at it
it's just like it's weird because the
eyes are there and it looks at you like
two days buddy what about like two days
like when people's looking at you yeah
all right what about lumpia or Taro okay
yeah yeah I had that too but um are you
an adventurous eater like will you do
the wacky kind of what are you talking
about maybe that was just maybe you lost
a bet he didn't see this over here have
you ever been in a focus group
no no no no okay I've been like um but
I've been like the subject of focus
groups sure why on the shows oh yeah of
course yeah you have to do um
you have to test like they test of
course right and they do focus groups
and you know what I love about being
like like with the way I look and I have
a round flat face you know what I mean
and I kind of look like if you don't
know my history like
you know I like if you know it like you
know like oh my God you know he's
adorable he's adorable he likes he looks
like an emoji you're right yeah and so I
love getting on a sitcom because I know
I'm gonna test time right so it's like I
always get like I did this uh one show
where they're like yeah you tested
higher than babies and monkeys
I'm like that's good right like it's
unbelievable like they don't have like a
meter to even like go there right that's
awesome it's awesome so it's like and
then they're always like you know um
they pick it up because like we got like
you know a baby monkey yeah we have the
cutest man alive yeah yeah and that's
why like Ken Jung probably does baby
monkey numbers yeah yeah baby yeah
ah uh so you go out to a restaurant with
the with friends right say Jew and
Santino or so going out to a nice din-in
I have a thing who's picking up that
chick
well Santina and I'm going to say that
I'm going to start a war and he's gonna
be so mad
but he I'm beginning to think let's uh
he disappeared I want to say that the
last meals he disappears really so right
before the check appears he goes I got a
golf thing or you know I mean oh [ __ ] I
got to go to Dave it's like you didn't
say you were going to shoot today right
there's something and then he leaves and
then the check comes and this happened
for the last eight times and I I've
never said it out loud before
I don't know if that's going to start
something with him he's paid before I
remember call I'm sure I'm sure you know
but the last guy he's a nice guy I love
a very talented guy but the last couple
has been a little suspect but you know
I'm gonna wait for the next meal see
what happens you know okay and let me
say the last one was maestros
have you ever heard of no maestros it's
a very expensive restaurant chain I
think I spent I'll just tell you what I
spent because it was with please do the
producer Andrew and a girl named jet ski
who's like a sidekick on bad friends
very talented girl she had never been to
a fancy restaurant so we took her
maestros and I think I dropped 750
dollars
and he left really right and it was kind
of you know it kind of irked me a bit
you know man I'm now expressing that and
don't edit that out I want to see what
that happens for a relationship edit
that out it's the clip what are you
talking about yeah yeah I want to see
what that happens okay I gotta say he's
not cheap he's been he's saved my life a
bunch of times and I love him he put
this in the clip too keep this in the
clip too he's a great guy right but I'm
just saying last couple times that's all
I mean I
to say this I gotta call Paul I love you
I gotta call brawls and Strikes down
750 bucks we dropped that yeah you gotta
be dropping are you kidding me dinner
I know a nice restaurant you think I
should be paying for it um that's a
haircut to you guys who gives a [ __ ]
that's getting coffee you come in here
all that that's what you hit me with
750. I got Tom Segura back here with a
52 000 check not included wait wait wait
wait wait wait that's his check that's
what he spent on his uh his birthday
dinner
all right so here's the deal about Tom
Segura right
can I say something about Thompson girl
have you had him out here we have that
was that he wrote that greatest guy
right love him love him the greatest guy
in the world but you know it's like
I never doesn't do stand up
ever I've never seen what the clubs are
not that right and I don't watch anybody
you know I mean I don't know what
anyone's doing he murders he's one of
the best I've ever seen yeah he killed
yeah he's one of the best and that's not
what I'm saying yeah let me follow this
logic follow this logic right so he's
just like he's like hey you want to do
show something in Canada this is last
week I saw you again yeah that's right
so I'm like oh [ __ ] that's right and I
show up
and it's like stadiums yeah
he ain't doing the [ __ ] yuck
he's huge he's great like I still play
like [ __ ] you know I mean Wise Guys
and sure yeah we were just a great club
right yeah I'll do the call you know uh
the Denver Comedy Works great clubs
great clubs but he's like like he's you
too yeah
it's crazy you're right principally 750
I should just eat that seven right
you're right I [ __ ] up right but
here's a little thing you're talking
about flying first class just killing
pillows and complain about 750 at a
dinner for a team but here's the deal
trash he spends out of McDonald's
and I will again yeah yeah why it's like
in the smell of gas garbage it is I
don't think the Kennedys are doing it no
my favorite is asphalt fresh Asphalt in
the summer no way asphalt's better than
God that takes me back away
car's okay maybe but gas is pretty much
I just think about that scene in shawl
shank when they're up there and that
that Hot Tar and the beer it's like very
oh yeah I can the the smell in that cold
beer [ __ ] hits me that beer looks
like it [ __ ] hit the spot yeah do you
drink if you have a drink what's your
drink
I like winding down red wine red wine
yeah and the whiskey I like Scotch good
scotch okay good and I like beer but I
don't drink much okay but those are the
three things I like very cold beer I
assume you've had a couple nice French
wine yeah I've had I've had some very
good french wine like I go crazy for
like a very good
friendship how expensive we thought yeah
what's the most expensive bottle of wine
you ever bought oh a lot two thousand
three thousand something like that yeah
wow yeah wow it has been a long time
since I've done that okay I live very
differently than I used to I used to
have gold watches
that's a sweet Shark watch yeah
once in a while I buy have a you know
heavy bottle of Scotch like a really
good a good watch and I keep that for a
long I don't it'll keep it for months
just sip on it yeah nice bottle of
Yellow Tail these days that's right I
think your finest box you have
um what if you're going to a dinner you
know at a friend's house uh and you're
breaking a bottle of wine do you have
like a go-to what's what are you what
are you spending around there anything
it depends on the friend right this is
what we get into yeah there's you got
the the wine that was brought to you
last
it's not gonna be what I like so I just
hold on to that until next time no one's
ever had that answer that's really smart
yeah you got to do that
says he watches the movie he sees Fourth
of July he says it's fantastic I want to
discuss how you guys came up with it how
you worked with someone like Joe list
how good are you guys I'm over my house
I want to discuss how you got this
performance out of this guy what do you
bringing there that's a difference
him or somebody I just really like and
feel or feel grateful to somebody you
know what I mean like that like somebody
who I'm like really wanna wow Lynch bag
uh 2005 if you can find it 2006 if you
can only find in 2006.
it's French it's um
l-y-n-c-h and then b-a-g-g-e-s I don't
know how to [ __ ] say it Lynch bag
yeah
let me get a 2022 Lynch bag but that's
about two to four hundred dollars that's
okay
or any kind of like uh margotes or good
okay son Julian kind of things sure any
of those uh in the range of two to four
hundred dollars Marcos are nice
yeah what do you like red wise you're a
Cabernet guy you're a Malbec guy what do
you like only those bordeaux's are just
really into French Portos I can get it I
was just in uh Copenhagen on tour and
our our
um promoter he's obsessed with
restaurants he's been to all the best
restaurants in the world he's one of
these guys sure he'll wait months to go
somewhere or whatever so he told me
Copenhagen is his favorite city for
restaurants and that he was sending me
to the best of this so it's his favorite
place and I did a pairing you know you
get a tasting menu with Shrine pairings
and they introduced me to our
um natural wine this is a noose thing
yes very new yeah so they start you with
the white one with a for they start you
with a champagne and then white and then
it gets like literally those orange
wines and then you get deeper red as you
the meal goes on and they're cloudy and
they're not there's no filtering they're
not like refined or anything nothing
it's just the Earth in it it's just yes
you can really and I that's what I like
about wine is being able to taste like I
feel like I could taste the weather when
it was and the the soil so these things
holy [ __ ] and there's a gamey like
almost rotten smell to them like [ __ ]
yeah
but the wines get and at one point I was
like I'm getting like I trusted them and
I'm like do people what do people do to
not get drunk and they go no you get
drunk yeah that's the point really
[ __ ] up and I had to I had to walk
along the buildings I mean I barely made
it back really you were that [ __ ] I
was blind was I almost I've never
blacked out drunk yeah never serving you
[ __ ] Copenhagen [ __ ] moonshine
like Sharon Stone and casino most of the
rising sun's place
and it was a bad day the next day you do
ice in the wine
uh how many suits do you own uh a lot
but I don't wear them anymore I had one
tour where I worked oh right right yeah
yeah and I got them because I I can't I
wear a suit and in 10 minutes I look
like a chef a bad account yeah it's like
a guy who's had a nervous break sure I'm
the same way I put on a suit fit me the
second I get into a car sit down it's
[ __ ] shirt comes up and out are the
pants are down tomorrow
it's hard like a fat kid at the end of a
wedding that's right [ __ ] cake on
your face that's it yeah but when I was
I was in San Francisco with my daughter
and we went to a thrift store and she
found a suit that it was like really
cool almost fit so I found a tailor in
San Francisco I'd never even been to one
and I said can you do this yeah and he
said yeah by the way I can make you
suits
you can get one just get whatever you
want and he wasn't expensive but he was
uh Peter Panos is his name and I I
picked just that day I picked a bunch
cool I decided that day I might wear
suits you can be a suit guy I'm gonna
wear suits I always want when I was a
kid I wanted to be a comedian in suits
sure
and uh so I had a bunch of shirts and
suits made by that guy like eight of
them and he sent to my worm a hole for a
whole tour of War suits yeah but I'm
done with it I'm not gonna do it again
any Armani or anything like that you got
at the house yeah like from a couple of
movies I was in that they let me keep
the suits Fiona tux I do want to text
because I used to go to Awards shows
every all the time yeah nice yes you
know tie a bow tie
uh yeah I could I used I did it a few
times I'd need a refresh off yeah I
don't know how to tie a regular tie
really is that garbage I don't think you
have a tux Mr list I don't know yeah I
got two suits nice suits right Ted Baker
baby
stuff Ted Baker yeah but I remember
hearing you talk about it I thought it
was somebody you knew I thought he was
like a fan or something that's how
trashy I was no Ted Baker you know Ted
bank account I remember when Ted Baker
was I don't know how long he's been
around but I think he was a new thing
uh-huh and I was with Chris Rock uh in
Aspen Colorado at a festival and there
was like a lot of people there's a lot
of
um uh activity people were excited a lot
of famous people there and Chris was
huge and I was nothing at the time and
uh somebody came up to us with a headset
and just said get in this van we're
taking everybody to and we're just
talking so we just let ourselves we put
it anyway next thing we know we're in a
Ted Baker store they had closed the
store for Chris and they said pick
whatever you want and it's yours and
Chris is a high class classy guy and he
said just he said to the girl you pick
me one shirt you pick it for me like
that's the kind of guy he is
leather jackets I said I want one of
these yeah and they're like
um are you Chris Rock sir they had to
unlock it it had a lock on it I was like
I want one of these because I was like
I'm never gonna be in here Chris is
trying to maintain this lifestyle I was
like this is burning to the ground this
is happening there you have it it's a
really good leather jacket that's
[ __ ] did you do Hands Across America
no no
you cooked eggs in the microwave you
actively cook eggs in the microwave not
only that you bought a poaching device
that's a double that's a triple that's a
triple stamp a double stamp the device
the Target and the action and the action
of microwaving eggs in an apparat your
poaching eggs which should be the
classiest version a postdoc is the
classiest thing if you did it right but
you didn't and you laughed at me when I
told you the procedure to cook the
poached egg what is it you pull it out
with one of those like
one of those Nets at the end but you
heat up you heat up about three inches
of boil of water you let it boil you
turn it off you drop the egg in there
from a separate cylinder you spin the
water before you put it in there until
it collects together and you put a dash
of vinegar in there that's class you
don't do that you microwave plastic yeah
it's been a long time this is something
I did in my poor days okay there was no
I was a Target it's an Impulse buy God
damn it you guys got me [ __ ] this is
the question no who wasn't that Target
making impulse buys the [ __ ] Kennedys
okay yeah
[Applause]
Jesus Christ I hate them I hate them it
is a brown egg though that is an organic
organic there isn't a more fun guy he's
disgusting all right breaking the fourth
wall he walked in his suit and I [ __ ]
jumped up I'm like this guy's [ __ ]
came to play Jesus well I can cross here
eating a hard-boiled egg off the list on
camera good God
and in fact my mom recently said my
sister excuse me said uh uh corn in the
microwave is actually as good as on the
grill and I said I said no it's not and
I won't eat it corn on the grill or
nothing
according to the microwave was okay oh
I'm gonna throw off Jesus Christ you
hate that like a [ __ ] Komodo dragon
he ate it like a snake dude
like a bald Jewish snake oh god oh that
smells like a [ __ ] 1992 Honda Civic
brutal
oh God that stinks man
[Laughter]
over my computer
we gotta move man
I'm throwing that computer away
God
thanks man
I'm gonna start doing that when I fart
I'm gonna whip out a hard-boiled egg it
made me laugh [ __ ] your pants the eggs
oh disgusting
there's one oh my God Mr shaffir
Hari also likes the chili cheese machine
at 7-Eleven I was a big fan of it if I
were oh yeah I did like it it's been a
while man it's been a while damn that
chili cheese was good I haven't had so
long now I'm starting to think maybe I
am
you are trash dude I don't
you're for sure shots all over my
screens it looks like someone egged me
it was a hard-boiled egg
you [ __ ] that's great sorry no it's
good you're good oh my God